dead spin ostensibly a sports news site
decided to help Jin up an outrage mob to
go after a child who committed the crime
of wearing a costume to a football game
now as you can see it is a side profile
of the kid with his headdress and what
appears to be black face paint you look
at that picture and there are a few ways
that you could possibly interpret other
photos taken at the game show that his
face paint is both black and red
matching his jersey and shirt
combination as you can clearly see here
it would not be national news if he was
wearing black face but obviously he's
not wearing black face any rational
person would know that automatically
without needing photographic evidence to
prove it